i always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people khloe kardashian is avoiding the
drama surrounding tristan thompson as
she reacts to her ex packing on the pda
with another woman and we're learning
more about their new dynamic as they
prepare to welcome baby number two i
wanted to believe that tristan could
change i wanted to trust him a lot has
changed since chloe found out about
tristan's paternity scandal on season
one of the kardashians when he welcomed
the baby boy with marylee nichols while
he was dating coco
earlier this week a fan account posted a
video of tristan walking hand in hand in
greece with an unknown woman and chloe
simply liked the post so what's with
koko's like well it seems like she's
supporting what was written in the fan's
caption
which reiterates tristan and chloe
haven't spoken since december aside from
co-parenting their daughter true so the
fact that tristan is enjoying the single
life not exactly a shock the caption
also points out koko's main focus as
long as he's a good dad to his baby
he's a really hands-on dad and so it's
just easy to co-parent with him the fan
account seems to be protecting coco's
piece and we see nothing wrong with that
probably why coco double tapped a source
tells e.t chloe doesn't care about
videos or pics circulating of tristan
with other women because they're done so
quote the two aren't a couple and don't
speak unless they are co-parenting
regardless of us being friends or
wherever we stand i think we both grow
together it just makes our family and
our bond just better you know it's
always
such a weird
gray area but our source says since the
scandal there's no more gray area for
chloe chloe has moved on and she's only
worried about what's best for
four-year-old truth i think everyone has
to handle their co-parenting situation
and their own style we've learned that
true spends most of her time with coco
but has an open door policy for tristan
to see the kids when he wants as for how
tristan and chloe plan to move forward
with a new baby on the way via surrogate
another source says tristan isn't trying
to win her back romantically and that
their relationship is strained but
tolerable
still chloe isn't letting anything
affect their growing family quote she is
refusing to let any negativity take away
from her and her family's joy about this
exciting new addition i just want to
live my life and be happy and the source
says chloe is super happy to be adding a
baby boy to the mix quote mostly because
she can't wait to give true a sibling
i'm focused on work and like taking care
of me my body and soul and true
[Music]
you